[Music]  i'm martha mccallum and i've been at fox  news for 17 years so when i came to fox  in 2004 it still had sort of that  scrappy feel it had been around for a  few years and uh it felt like you could  kind of you could do anything i was  lucky because i landed right in the  middle of an election year i basically  said you know i'll stand on the street  corner in boston and talk about the  traffic coming in and out of town i had  not had a history covering politics so  they took a gamble on me martha mccallum  fox news but i would always encourage  people to ask for  the opportunity that you want i mean the  worst that can happen is somebody's  going to say no so now i get to sit at  the big desk and work with brett but i  never forget where it all began with  saying pick me i'd like to have this  opportunity  people like it when you say i'm willing  to take on that challenge